political differences are put aside in
the face of the novel coronavirus the US
House of Representatives agrees to
allocate eight point three billion
dollars the bulk of funds going to the
agencies dealing directly with the
crisis Congress is acting with the
seriousness and sense of urgency
the corona virus threat demands
President Trump held a meeting with
airline CEOs to discuss the impact of
the virus on the travel industry the
Vice President was effusive about
Misha's he says the president has taken
to protect US citizens the American
people deserve to know that according to
all our experts the risk to the average
American of contracting the corona virus
remains low and that's largely owing to
your decision mr. president to suspend
all travel from China into the United
States and the quarantine of all
Americans that are returning an attempt
at reassuring words - from the
administration's response coordinator
ensuring that if you touched anything
you go and wash your hands again 20
seconds with soap hand sanitizers also
work but I think I was very reassured to
hear the airline's talk about their
cleaning procedures and there are three
levels of cleaning procedures because I
think that it will be reassuring to the
American public and I haven't touched my
face at winxs a number of US schools
have been closed as a precautionary
measure Authority stressing that it's
because of the flu season rather than a
direct response to the corona virus and
soldiers arriving for basic training of
being screened as yet none have tested
positive but as recorded deaths from the
corona virus move into double figures
the Center for Disease Control says it
has heightened concerns and it's
broadened the criteria for doctors to
legally enforce the testing of patients
for the virus Michener al jazeera
Washington